talk about twinning uma thurman and her
20 year old daughter Maya's family
resemblance was on full display at the
Giorgio Armani Prive spring/summer show
at Paris Fashion Week
[Applause]
the mother-daughter duo sat front row at
the celeb packed affair
here they are squeezed in between the
Celine Dion and Amber Heard now it's
safe to say we'll be seeing a lot more
of Maia around she's making a name for
herself as a bit of a fashion plate
she's joined to the cast of stranger
things season 3 I can't help that I like
boys clothes and work and manners and
she got rave reviews for her work and
the BBC's the latest adaptation of A
Little Women I always really connected
to Jo and so I feel lucky that I got to
play that character now it seems safe to
assume her parents are proud Bert for me
to see my own daughter playing Louisa
May Alcott's you know alter-ego at this
moment in 2018 when all this times up
stuff is happening it feels like a great
time to be a young woman and an exciting
this gonna be an exciting 50 years ahead
of her dad Ethan Hawke gushed over
Maya's big break last year she was going
to Juilliard and she got the part of
Jill March and the BBC's production a
little women and my mother said to me
well you gonna tell her to stay in
school you try you look her in the eyes
and tell her she can't play Jo March you
know the truth of the matter is if you
can do something else you should it's a
very hard life probably any of the arts
but particularly acting because there's
never enough success and there's always
another failure
Maya is willing ready and able she's
going all-in
you
[Music]
[Applause]